zurück bei begleiter diesem sonntag ein
massaker in europa im jahr
2022 putin geht es um die vernichtung
der ukraine wir zeigen ihnen jetzt
bilder aus einem vorort von kers es sind
bilder die kaum zu ertragen sind eine
brutalität die nicht vorstellbar ist
jetzt zeigen diese bilder aufgrund der
würde dieser menschen verpixelt doch die
welt muss von den kriegsverbrechen die
putins drucken beginn erfahren eine
kleinstadt nordwestlich von kiew tote
überall sie waren im sand verscharrt
unter dieser plane sollen fünf takte
frauenleichen liegen immer wieder die
rede von den vergewaltigungen die
menschen dort sie werden wieder gewinne
gemetzelt sie sehen dort menschen am
boden liegen denn hände gefesselt sind
zivilisten die sich nicht wehren konnten
diese bilder zeigen kriegsverbrechen
absolute
unmenschlichkeit die straßen in butter
sind mit leichen übersät manchmal als 20
tote körper nur einer straße sagt der
bürgermeister dort die menschen dort
wurden wieder gewechselt teilweise
notdürftig vergraben im sand und 300
menschen oder wie hier in einem gully
geworfen die leiche dran hat menschen in
massengräbern jetzt beerdigt wenn man
das so nennen können kann diese menschen
sind wehrlos diese menschen waren
zivilisten
[Musik]
bild breaking news
denn angesichts dieser bilder aus butter
haben wir mit wirtschaftsminister robert
habeck gesprochen und er hat uns eben
gerade das gesagt er sagt dieses
furchtbare kriegsverbrechen kann nicht
unbeantwortet bleiben ich halte eine
verschärfung der sanktionen für
angezeigt dass breiten wir zusammen mit
unseren partnern in der europäischen
union vor ja und auch die europäische
union hat vor wenigen minuten
angekündigt man wolle eine untersuchung
dieser gräueltaten in den kirchen vor
ort unterstützen und über diese wirklich
unerträglichen bilder aus butter hat der
ukrainische verteidigungsminister alexej
resnik auf gerade gegenüber bild dass
ihr gesagt
um es kurz zu machen es war ein echtes
militärisches kriegsverbrechen wir
warten auf neue nürnberger prozesse ich
denke die deutschen kennen die
nürnberger prozesse bestens die nächsten
nürnberger prozesse sind gegen die
russischen faschistischen ja dass also
die erwartungen von ukrainischer seite
wir haben auch mit vitali klitschko dem
bürgermeister der stadt kiew gesprochen
paul ronzheimer konnte ihn exklusiv
sprechen und er benennt diese
gräueltaten ganz klar und fordert von
deutschland auf endlich konsequenzen zu
ziehen dass ihr sagt vitali klitschko er
sagt dass wir es in bhutan anderen
vororten von kiew passiert ist kann man
nur als völkermord bezeichnet
es sind grausame kriegsverbrechen die
putin dort zu verantworten hat
zivilisten die mit verbundenen händen
erschossen wurden für die ganze welt und
insbesondere deutschlands kann es nur
eine konsequenz geben kein cent darf mir
nach russland gehen das ist blutiges
geld mit dem menschen abgeschlachtet
werden das gas und öl embargo muss
sofort kommen und ich spreche jetzt mit
zehn michael wenzel r ist der
deutschlanddirektor von human rights
watch guten tag herr wenzel
auch sie haben informationen über
kriegsverbrechen in russisch
kontrollierten gebieten gesammelt welche
informationen haben sie haben ja auch
mit zeugen dort gesprochen
ja wir haben gerade in diesen gebieten
die sie eben genannt haben auch in
butter schon anfang märz mit menschen
gesprochen
die uns berichtet haben das haben wir
jetzt auch dokumentiert und beweise
gesammelt von ähnlichen keul taten die
wir jetzt auf diesen bildern gesehen
haben zum beispiel haben wir ein bericht
aus butter vom 4 märz da wurden fünf
zivilisten männer gezwungen sich
hinzuknien ihre t shirt übrigens über
kopf zu ziehen und einer von den männern
wurde dann in den kopf geschossen
erschossen wir haben berichte von
vergewaltigung von anderen sexuellen
gewalttaten
wir haben gerichte vom einsatz von
verbotenen waffen wie zum beispiel
streumunition in einem dorf in der nähe
von kiew da wurde eine
rauchgranate eine eine nebelgranate in
ein haus geworfen eine mutter mit ihrem
14 jährigen sohn kamen aus dem haus und
die wurden dann erschossen also das sind
so einige beispiele der
grausamkeiten der eigentlich
unaussprechlich raus am greifen die
russlands soldaten dort in den
ukrainischen gebieten
geben ja sehen sie das derzeit begrenzt
auf die vororte rund um kirch vor der
ist also davon auszugehen dass es das
gesamte kriegsgebiet betrifft ja wir
haben ähnliche berichte auch aus kharkiv
zum beispiel gerne hilft und was man
auch sonst so sieht selbst wenn man in
ordnung vielleicht gerade nicht mit
leuten sprechen kann weil der zugang zu
schwierig ist und die dort noch nicht
mal telefone haben alle allein das was
wir auf den bildern sehen die
ausgebrannten wohnhäuser auch das sind
schon kriegsverbrechen
die kriegs gesetze verbieten zivilisten
gezielt anzugreifen gezielt zu töten und
das sehen wir eben methodisch und
systematisch von der russischen armee
das heißt welche konsequenzen kann jetzt
folgen was muss jetzt passieren
wir sammeln beweise
und hoffen dass diese beweise irgendwann
mal
für gerichtsverfahren zugänglich gemacht
werden und benutzt werden so ähnlich wie
wir das auch in syrien gemacht haben wir
hatten gerade in koblenz ein
prozess und eine verurteilung von assad
folterknechten da hat man auch unsere
beweise
benutzt das erhoffen wir uns natürlich
auch die ukraine krieg aber natürlich
auch untersuchungen und das klingt jetzt
vielleicht so ein bisschen naiv aber
natürlich ist auch die russische
regierung in der pflicht diese
gräueltaten zu untersuchen und zu ahnden
es wird nicht passieren und deswegen
brauchen wir
herr klitschko vorhin schon gesagt hat
natürlich eine art nürnberger prozesse
also ein
gerichtsprozess der diese gräueltaten
aufklärt auch noch mal von juristischer
seite und dann die entsprechende
menschen verurteilt verkauf der
verteidigungsminister der ukraine sagte
dies eventuell vielen herzlichen dank
für ihre einschätzungen zu diesem
grausamen thema an diesem sonntag dann
kennen